Hello connected data London folk. The
semantic web industry has delivered on a
great many things and we're very very
pleased with its success in a great
number of ways. Uh but there are a few
things that quite frankly haven't quite
delivered the way that people have
expected certainly not when they come to
the industry when they come to the
technology set.
And I'm going to try to address a few of
those fundamental often maligned
issues that people have come across.
Um the questions that I'm going to try
to answer are questions that people
often have such as number one, where do
I go to find an ontology?
Where can I go to pull an ontology?
Where is the repository of ontologies?
We've had service in services in the
past like the LOD cloud that which show
wonderful diagrams and through no fault
of their own have links to things which
supposedly are data sets and ontologies
but just after a few clicks
will expose the fact that maybe those
links are no longer exist. There isn't
really anything wrong with a LODC cloud.
I think it's a wonderful um service but
it is a symptom. It does expose a
symptom.
Um, and I think this is because there
isn't really there there never really
has been any sort of npm or maven
repository for ontologies. There are
certain things like the OBO foundry that
have done an attempt to do this for the
life sciences community and others for
other communities. FIBO uh the EDMA, the
EDM association certainly does this with
their particular uh favored ontologies
like FIBO. But there's no central
registry when a newcomer can go and find
what they're looking for and check it
out. And it's not versioned. It's not
pinned to a specific version. So what I
want to talk about is partly how
we can overcome
that particular issue and make
knowledge graph technologies truly more
accessible to people uh through their
ontologies and also
how not only that but we can pin it to a
version and
have some sort of validation that the
data you're going to process will
conform to those versions of those
ontologies. So there's also an element
of shackle here which I think you'll
find very interesting.
I think this is some of my finest work
and I would be delighted if I get the
opportunity to share it with you this
winter.